bonjour madame
on m'a demandé quelle grande découverte
de physique
faire d'ici 2050 et je sais absolument
pas vous répondre
donc ça peu à peu près s'arrêter là et
je pense qu'on aura fait le taux que le
plus court de l'histoire des ted
j'ai quand même encore 17 minutes et 40
secondes donc faut que je tienne
donc j'ai essayé de me dire bon alors
quand même qu'est ce que je vais pouvoir
le raconter de ce qui pourrait se passer
dans les années à venir en physique donc
comme tout bon scientifique j'essaie de
regarder un petit peu ce qui se passait
avant pour extrapoler
donc je me suis dit ok sur 34 35 ans
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire comme
découverte en physique et qu'est ce qui
nous attend dans les années à venir donc
j'ai regardé dans le passé alors j'ai
pris 1900 à 1935
donc c'est les plus belles années de la
physique selon moi alors évidemment
quand on regarde la photo ça a pas l'air
très fun à l'époque là une femme c'est
marie curie qui est là au premier rang
il ya des hommes tous d'un certain âge
mais en réalité ces physiciens la 20-30
physicien européen pour la plupart vont
en 20 ans révolutionné la physique
moderne révolutionné la compréhension
qu'on a de la mécanique et de la gravité
ça c'est einstein au premier rang qui va
inventer la théorie de la relativité
restreinte puis général et puis
révolutionné la compréhension qu'on a de
la matière l'atome le photon l'électron
va comprendre tout ça avec l'arrivée de
la physique quantique et toutes les
autres personnes en gros sont l'image
ont permis de construire la physique
quantique ensemble en 20 ans à peu près
une théorie incroyablement performante
et qui marche encore de nos jours
parfaitement pour comprendre la physique
la chimie et la plupart des phénomènes
qui nous entoure donc en 30 35 ans à des
révolutions absolument majeur si on
regarde plus récemment les 35 dernières
années
alors là beaucoup de gens me disent oh
là là à vous maintenant les physiciens
vous êtes dans le raffinement les
grandes révolutions ou lieu ça y est la
physique quantique la relativité
générale les particules élémentaires et
maintenant vous êtes en train de
vérifier la cinquième ou sixième
décimales
alors je suis ici d'être honnête j'ai
pris les 35 dernières années j'essaie de
regarder s'il y avait eu des découvertes
importantes pour l'humanité en 35 ans or
la réponse c'est oui on a on a bossé
celle là elle date de 2012 c'est le
boson de higgs le boson de higgs qui a
vraiment permis de confirmer le modèle
standard et on l'attendait depuis
longtemps mais n'y a pas eu que le boson
de higgs en regardant par exemple les
étoiles et les étoiles qui explosent les
supernovas on s'est rendu compte que
l'univers autour de nous et est en
expansion ça on le savait déjà mais que
cette expansion s'accélère de plus en
plus vite quand on a regardé le fond de
l'univers on s'est rendu compte que le
fond de l'univers rayonnait très
légèrement ce rayonnement au sein du big
bang et on a été capable fin des années
80 en fin de mesurer précisément ce
rayonnement on appelle ça le fond diffus
cosmologique c'est l'empreinte sait ce
qui nous reste du big bang et avec ça on
est vraiment capable de comprendre
comment l'univers est né
on a regardé les étoiles dans le ciel on
s'est rendu compte que les étoiles
tourner un peu bizarrement c'est cette
espèce de genre de courbe
là on est milieu des années 90 en 94 95
cette courbe est là et la première
signature du fait que autour d'une
étoile ya une planète qui tourne
c'était la première fois qu'on observait
une planète hors du système solaire une
exoplanète
maintenant je crois qu'on observait 2000
à peu près et ça ça date des 20
dernières années
et puis un autre échelle dans les
laboratoires on a inventé des nouveaux
outils absolument incroyable ça c'est un
de mes préférés c'est un microscope à
effet tunnel inventé milieu des années
80 et qui permet avec une pointe et un
peu de physique quantique de voir les
atomes dans la matière ce genre d'image
d'atomes on savait pas les faire quand
moi j'étais au lycée où l'on commençait
tout juste à ça vous permet de calculer
très vite l'âge que j'ai pensé
maintenant faire ses images les non
seulement on sait voir les atomes dans
la matière mais on sait les manipuler
avec le même genre d'outil si par
exemple on fabrique un transistor à un
atom le petit nez de clown que vous
voyez au milieu c'est un atome on est en
train en fait d'inventer la nano
physique et les nanotechnologies
on manipule la matière à l'échelle du
nanomètre on sait manipuler et fabriquer
des nanotubes du graphène et des tas
d'outils incroyable pour révolutionner
alors peut-être l'électronique de demain
et surtout notre compréhension du monde
à l'échelle du nano et puis alors ma
découverte préféré de façon complètement
subjective c'est celle là puisque j'ai
travaillé 20 ans sur ces machins là donc
ça s'est découvert milieu des années 80
c'est des cuprates supraconducteurs
c'est la patinoire sous l'espèce de
merde azote liquide qu'on voit ici et
qui fait léviter les aimants qui conduit
le courant parfaitement et qui a été
découvert au milieu des années 80 des
températures très élevées on n'a pas
encore bien compris pourquoi ces
matériaux sont supraconducteurs et c'est
un des sujets de recherche les plus
étudiés actuellement qui a complètement
révolutionné notre façon de comprendre
les métaux et les oxydes 1 donc en fait
en trente cinq ans il s'est passé plein
de trucs
ce qui me conforte encore plus dans
l'idée que je ne sais pas dû
prévoir quelles grandes découvertes y
aura dans les trente cinq années à venir
et ce qui aura un grand bouleversement
théorie fondamentale est-ce qu'au
contraire on va être dans des
découvertes de nouveaux phénomènes ou de
nouveaux matériaux ou de nouveaux
comportements
j'en sais rien et il ya une raison assez
profondes pour laquelle je ne sais pas
du tout j'essaie de vous illustrer un
peu et qui a été un peu théorisée par
thomas skoun c'est l'idée que en fait la
science ça n'avance pas progressivement
linéairement alors si je regarde de loin
on pourrait penser ça mais de presse à
fait comme ça voyez ça mandefu les
accidents très soudain en général et
physicien il arrive par exemple fin du
19e siècle avec une ou deux expériences
qui leur résistent ça résiste de plus en
plus à cristalina cristallise et pouf
niels bohr einstein planque on
révolutionne de compréhension et on
redémarre et paradis en quelque sorte de
révolution scientifique qui vont arriver
et donc il y en aura peut-être peut-être
pas je n'en sais rien à mon avis c'est
pas la bonne question à se poser la
bonne question à se poser c'est est ce
qu'on en a encore besoin
après tout est ce qu'on devrait pas
maintenant se concentrer essentiellement
sur d'autres matières comme la biologie
par exemple la neuro nous ce qui se
passe dans le cerveau ou la génétique ou
la chimie moderne
est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin de
continuer à explorer la physique y
compris la physique fondamentale dans la
vie je suis physicien évidemment ma
réponse est oui
ayez un vrai argument du point de vue
l'humanité pour le coup c'est que tous
les problèmes auxquels on va devoir
faire face vont avoir besoin à un moment
donné de physique pour trouver une
solution
on va pas trouver toutes les solutions
dans la physique mais la physique va
nous aider
exemple simple tous les problèmes
énergétiques si vous pensez aux énergies
renouvelables face et les cellules
photovoltaïques
ça c'est de l'invention de physiciens de
physique quantique c'est l'effet
photoélectrique c'est la physique
quantique pelure plus de la physique des
matériaux plus de la physique des
solides et de la nano physique
si on veut améliorer ses photopiles ces
cellules photovoltaïques même trouvé de
quoi les remplacer pour être encore plus
efficaces pour résoudre les problèmes
d'énergie d'environnement d'effet de
serre on va avoir besoin physique et de
physique lourdin de physique délicate
donc il va nous falloir des physiciens
et des tas de super découverte est donc
la bonne question c'est comment s'en
assurer alors si je suis président de la
république demain et que je dois faire
un grand programme pour soutenir la
physique
j'ai deux options en gros il y en a une
c'est je fais des programmes jeu mais 20
milliards sur les cellules
photovoltaïques par exemple et puis vous
bossez vous ne trouvez des meilleurs
cellules photovoltaïques alors ça en
général ça marche très mal
les programmes très guider ce que nous
raconte l'histoire des sciences c'est
que ce qui marche plutôt c'est de dire
je vais essayer de repérer les biens
physicien et leur donner de l'argent et
leur dire faites ce que vous avez envie
c'est affreux comme paris on n'a pas du
tout confiance qu'on connaît les
physiciens
mais c'est un pari qui s'est toujours à
veiller avéré payant
c'est le pari la recherche fondamentale
c'est un moment de dire aux gens on vous
a bien formés vous êtes des physiciens
vous avez un bon cerveau on vous donne
de l'argent travailler sur ce dont vous
avez envie ce dont vous êtes curieux
faites ce que vous voulez on verra bien
si ça sert et si vous regardez toutes
les grandes découvertes où la plupart
des grandes découvertes du 20e siècle
elles se sont fait comme ça donc la
vraie bonne question maintenant si vous
acceptez de faire ce pari là c'est juste
de fermer des bons physicien si vous
formez des bons physiciens pour 2050 a
priori tout ira bien et maintenant se
pose la vraie question est la vraie
difficulté
alors comment on ferme des physiciens
jusqu'à présent en moi je suis
professeur à l'université donc je peux
vous dire comment je fais je sais à peu
près comme einstein à l'époque et comme
un professeur plus récemment je suis là
dans un amphithéâtre j'ai un tableau
noir ou un powerpoint et je vous raconte
la physique puis ensuite vous les
étudiants vous allez en train de diriger
faire des applications puis en travaux
pratiques puis peut-être vous fait un
stage en laboratoire et à la fin vous
avez compris la physique qui vous
recommencez vous même ce schéma et ça ça
marche très bien depuis quelques
centaines d'années nos petits problèmes
qu'on commence à ressentir nous mêmes en
enseignant à l'université c'est que nos
étudiants ont changé change et vont
changer encore plus parce qu'ils ont un
rapport au savoir qui en train de
radicalement évolué ils n'apprennent
plus la même manière ils ont leur
smartphone dans la poche qui leur donne
accès à wikipedia instantanément ils ont
l'impression qu'ils savent tout si on
leur laisse internet
ils ne savent plus vraiment lire un
livre un vrai livre de physique comme
cela là j'ai vu qu'il y avait les cours
de feynman magnifique clip de physique
j'ai plus beaucoup d'étudiants qui prend
le contre et de manier qui vend
pagesjaunes paj deux pages trois mois je
faisais ça à l'époque donc un rapport au
savoir qu'ils changent je dis pas qu'ils
apprennent moins bien ou mieux jeudi
qu'ils apprennent différemment et donc
va falloir adapter la façon qu'on a
d'enseigner la physique
alors comment faire ça donc ça nous on
essaie d'y travailler dans le groupe
à lire ces paris sud alors plusieurs
manières plusieurs pistes pour enseigner
la physique différemment pour essayer
d'utiliser de nouveaux outils justement
utilisons un ipad utilisant un
smartphone ça c'est ce que fait mon
collègue joël chevrier il fait tout les
causes mécaniques à grenoble avec un
smartphone il dit aux gens que vous avez
un gyroscope dans votre smartphone un
accéléromètre vous avez un magnétomètre
vous avez tout ce qu'il vous faut
suspendez le à une corde et puis on
mesure il
on des mesures de pendule d'accélération
et autres le smartphone devenant l'outil
de physique que l'étudiant a dans sa
poche et au delà du gaz et le voyez
c'est une autre manière d'impliquer
l'étudiant dans l'apprentissage
nous on a essayé de faire ça d'accepter
car tu sais les cartes ar beenox achète
pour 20 euros sur internet qui sont dans
un monde de l'open source et qui
permettent en fait en réalité en général
à des gens de la robotique de fabriquer
des robots marrant ou à des artistes des
designers ou même des enfants de faire
des gadgets rigolos qui réagissent à des
signaux ou à des stimuli avec des
capteurs en fait c'est un merveilleux
outil de physique mais qu'on n'utilise
jamais pour faire de la physique
donc nous on a dit à nos étudiants
malaisie prenez cet outil iv qui va vous
laisser très libre parce que ça coûte
pas cher et que vous pouvez le cas c'est
ce qu'ont fait pas normalement dans nos
tpe habituel et bien inventer la
physique que vous avez envie et
choisissez que deux sujets le matin et
essayez donc ça par exemple c'est des
étudiants qui ont essayé avec des négos
une arduino de faire une balance super
compliqué de faire une bonne balance en
physique et donc avec ça ils vont faire
de la physique qui ont pouvoir la
partager en ligne également et donc on
invente une nouvelle façon en quelque
sorte d'impliquer les étudiants en
physique
autre idée essayez d'utiliser d'autres
façons de participer vous avez vu on a
déjà un peu évoqués çà on peut pousser
un peu plus loin ça par exemple c'est
des collègues de l'université à aarhus
au danemark qui ont fait des jeux vidéo
pour apprendre la physique quantique à
leurs étudiants donc en jouant aux jeux
vidéo étape par étape vous allez
commencer à comprendre ce qu'est un peu
de potentiel ce qui est un atom ce qui
est un piégeage quantique etc etc
il travaille beaucoup à cette idée de
transformer en jeu vidéo l'apprentissage
de la science wikipédia on essaie
demandé à nos élèves de contribuer eux
mêmes à wikipedia en les accompagnant
l'idée c'est vous allez apprendre mais
en même temps vous même vous allez
participer à de la co construction d'un
nouvel enseignement ou d'un savoir
nouveau donc vous allez recycler ce que
vous apprenez et peut-être que ça vous
impliquera plus dans votre apprentissage
de la physique
dans ce même esprit pardon on a monté
une option de vulgarisation nadia nos
élèves revenaient dans notre façon ça va
être marrant vous allez faire la
vulgarisation et en fait sans leur dire
nous ce qu'on avait en tête c'est quand
vous allez devoir vulgariser un sujet de
physique par exemple de physique
quantique à l'équation de schrödinger
falloir vous la comprenez sacrément bien
avant de pouvoir l'expliquer aux autres
donc ça par exemple ces trois étudiants
qui ont voulu travailler sur les
exoplanètes dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure et qui ont fabriqué un cluedo où
vous devez gagner le prix nobel est donc
étape par étape avec tout un système de
questions et de parcours vous allez
essayer à en découdre
en plein d'exoplanètes et en collaborant
avec les autres de gagner le prix nobel
avant tout le monde et eux mêmes au
passage ont dû énormément en apprendre
sur les exoplanètes pour construire ce
jeu autre exemple alors que ouais il
était un peu trash
il voulait absolument faire un truc live
dans l'amphithéâtre donc c'est un match
de boxe enstone contre newton qui
s'affrontent à coups de vrais coups de
poing et d'arguments de physique pour
essayer de voir si c'est la relativité
générale ou la mécanique newtonienne
classique qui gagne à la fin
et le match était serré avec un arbitre
au milieu autre exemple alors il voulait
aller dans la rue dont qu'ils avaient
avec des bouts de scotch réinventer le
time avec du scotch
on appelle ça du theil art pour
expliquer ici alors voulait tous reconnu
imagine l'effet photoélectrique à la
base de la physique quantique dont qui
sont là devant les gens dans la rue avec
leurs bouts de scotch pour essayer
d'expliquer l'effet photoélectrique au
grand public évidemment à travers toutes
ces façons de faire on est en train
d'essayer de changer leur rapport à la
physique et leur mode de participation à
un cours de physique autre façon
peut-être d'enseignés différemment la
physique c'est en la représentant
différemment alors je dis pas qu'on va
changer le formalisme mathématique du
jour au lendemain ça j'y crois pas trop
ça marche bien les maths quand même été
solide et ses robustes et même si c'est
difficile à apprendre il faut souvent
passer par là mais peut-être par contre
les modes de représentation graphique on
peut essayer de les faire évoluer un
petit peu on va peut-être pas échappé au
graff x y met dans plein d'autres
phénomènes on peut cibler montrer
différemment pour à nouveau peut-être
mieux séduire le public
nous on essaye de travailler à sa
notamment avec des designers et avec des
illustrateurs
on a monté un groupe de recherche qui
s'appelle la physique autrement on
n'essaie pas de faire la physique
autrement mais de la montrer autrement à
la fois un enseignement et au grand
public et on a développé tout un tas de
ressources comme ça et essayer
d'explorer d'autres façons de montrer la
physique par exemple on a fait des tas
d'animations en physique quantique pour
essayer de montrer ici par exemple un
atom 1 atone c'est une boîte électrique
qui contient des fonctions dans de
cantiques et on les rajoutent les unes
au dessus des autres et ça vous décrit
tous les atomes de la classification
périodique en voyant né dans un langage
graphique assez simple assez épuré assez
moderne par rapport aux canons habituels
de la représentation
et puis pour les enfants on s'est dit
absolument il fallait faire un truc sur
la physique quantique évidemment et sur
les atomes donc on a fait des ateliers
de pliage pour les enfants où on leur
demande de plier des atomes
donc il ya un petit patron d'adp suivent
un truc et c'est comprendre les échelles
la forme le pliage rappelons un peu
cette idée
fonctionnant de quantic plus ou moins et
on peut arriver des pillages assez
sophistiqué ici par exemple vous aurez
reconnu une orbitale de l'atome de
cuivre les enfants en tous les cas son
hyper au point à la fin de l'atelier
autre exemple on avait absolument envie
d'essayer de travailler que les
équations elles mêmes souvent en cash
les équations s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait faire avec une équation
donc ça c'est l'équation de schrödinger
à la base de toute la physique quantique
et le chat de schrödinger qui va essayer
d'expliquer l'équation dans un petit
langage de gifs animés
alors là c'est trop dinger lui-même qui
est la fonction d'onde quantique donc ce
terme là vous dit si je redis guère
bougé au cours du temps ce terme là vous
dit ce sera dinger et courbet ou pas le
tmb il vous dit si freud inger subi des
forces ou subie l'électricité ou ce
casse la figure 1 et donc voyez on est
en train d'essayer de désacraliser
chacun des termes de l'équation en les
montrant de façon imagée je dis pas
qu'on a compris les mathématiques de
l'équation de schrödinger à travers ça
mais au moins on sent peut-être un petit
peu mieux ce que chaque t en veux dire
autre exemple ça c'est un petit film
qu'on a fait en stop motion avec une
étudiante des arts déco où on voulait
absolument essayer d'expliquer toute la
physique avec une tasse à café puisque
la tasse à café c'est quand même
l'élément central d'un labo de physique
trop qu'on avait assez des physiciens
devant une tasse à café lors d alors tu
vois quoi toi je vois un café non mais
alors qu'est ce que tu vois de plus et
donc qu'ils essayaient développer ce
qu'ils voyaient et à partir de là on a
construit un film que je vous encourage
à aller voir qui s'appelle physique et
caféine pour essayer de montrer tous les
champs de la physique à travers une
tasse à café
voyez ce qui compte ici c'est pas cette
histoire de tasses à café mais c'est le
langage graphique qu'on utilise qui
n'est pas celui des bouquins de physique
habituel qui est un langage en stop
motion en papier etc etc
et puis il peut être la dernière façon
ils avaient sûrement plein d'autres mais
que nous en explore pour enseigner la
physique autrement c'est déjà de penser
dans un premiers temps mais est-ce qu'on
va avoir des étudiants ce qu'on m'a
souvent je vois des gens essaient de
réfléchir ou bonne pédagogie de la
physique le premier truc c'est que les
étudiants y viennent dès le départ c'est
qu'ils aient envie de faire des études
de physique donc un moment donné il faut
se poser la question de la séduction
il faut se demander comment est-ce qu'on
peut captiver le public avec de la
physique lui montrer que la physique
c'est formidable parce que la physique
c'est formidable et que après ça
évidemment ils viennent en tant
qu'étudiants et que là on les déçoive
pas et qu'on trouve des nouvelles façons
de leur enseigne la physique
donc nous on essaie de beaucoup
travaillé aussi avec la vulgarisation
vis-à-vis du grand public dans des
musées de sciences dans des collèges
dans des lycées
dans la rue pour essayer de trouver
d'autres façons de montrer la physique
au grand public en le captivant
on va prendre les traits physiques bien
lourd par exemple la bear et france 2
les fêtes physique donc ça irait fera
j'en sais un matériau qui va modifier
les polarisation des ondes
électromagnétiques
le scotch fait ça par exemple et en
travaillant avec des designers ils ont
sorti cet objet là qui juste entre deux
polariseur révèle vous voyez espèce de
kaléidoscope très élégant avec lequel
les gens peuvent jouer et qui en réalité
révèle lahbiri présence du scotch qui
normalement très transparent autre
exemple ici pour montrer la
supraconductivité la lévitation
quantique
on a fabriqué avec un designer un petit
cirque en bois on va dans les écoles
avec ce petit cirque
on va même voir les plus vieux
maintenant les collégiens et les lycéens
le grand public
et voyez avec des petits animaux rigolos
on est en train de montrer un effet
physique pure qui est la lévitation
supraconductrice que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure là on est en train de
recouvrir l'oiseau de l'azoté liquide
vous voyez que l'on se décale par
rapport à l'expérience physique de base
on la met dans un environnement plus
ludique plus rigolo plus sympathique
mais la physique reste là évidemment et
on va nous interroger sur cette physique
ou là ça bug car je passe au suivant
c'était pour montrer les équations de
maxwell avec des illustrateurs ont
fabriqué un livre en pop up qui révèle
dans un univers très graphique pour
enfants l'équation propagation des ondes
électromagnétiques
quand même ça par exemple c'était une
tour eiffel qu'on a fabriqué devant la
vraie tour eiffel donc chaque étage
levitte au dessus de laitages précédent
et avec ça on a attiré sur un stand du
cnrs 20 à 30000 personnes pour venir
voir la tour eiffel flottante
bon elle fait juste 30 cm a l'air un peu
ridicules de tour eiffel mais elle a
beaucoup plus et une fois que les gens
venaient vu qu'il fallait toute façon 20
minutes pour la refroidir on pouvait
vraiment leur parler de physique
quantique et les captiver nos collègues
de paris cédant même gens ont fabriqué
un sort supraconducteurs cette même
année et où il faisait flotter les gens
sur le sort supraconducteurs comme
retour vers le futur
vous voyez l'idée de ne pas hésiter à
utiliser des gadgets hyper high tech est
hyper séduisant pour emmener les gens
dans notre univers de physiciens donc si
je reviens à ma question de départ
finalement la bonne question à mon avis
qu'il faut se poser c'est est ce qu'on
aura encore des physiciens en 2050
je ne sais pas répondre à cette question
malheureusement je ne sais pas dire oui
peut-être qu'on en aura mais de mauvaise
qualité
ça n'a rien de gagné
à mon avis c'est une question cruciale
je pense que c'est une question cruciale
pas seulement pour nous physicien mais
pour toute la société et pour l'avenir
de l'humanité
merci